let's bring in our friend from espn
fresh off of his
first uh big mock draft they had a whole
show about it on the worldwide leader in
sports
our friend todd mcshea back here on the
rich eisen show how are you todd
doing well rick how you doing man i am
doing fine uh i mean i'm looking at
these cap numbers right that teams are
trying to build
around their quarterbacks right now and
i'm wondering would i rather be in a
boat
with say uh lamar jackson
taking up only 1.6 of my cap jared uh
josh allen 3.6
of my cap or would i rather be in the
boat like say
with dak 10
jimmy g 13 and a half mahomes 13
aaron rodgers 20 i'm wondering if this
is the stuff that you're talking about
with evaluators also as they're looking
at all 22.
yeah it's part of it it really is and
what you have to decide is
are you getting something equal to or
better than what you
currently have at that position and
that's that's really the struggle and
and are where you are drafting are you
capable of getting a
player that you think could be is as
good as the quarterback that you have
and that's i mean
that's a struggle right now we know that
jacksonville is going to take
trevor lawrence with that first pick and
then after that it's
it's all up in the air you know what do
the jets do with sam darnold
you know are there they're going to move
him for in part because of these reasons
and maybe in part because they love zach
wilson if that's the case
you know that's the the organizational
struggle that's going on with a lot of
these teams especially the ones that are
that are picking high
you know in this year's draft so then
let's break it down then
let's get into that jet's decision what
do you think their decision is
you know on darnold and or zack wilson
or using a lot of their draft capital
that they have earned
by trading away players like say the
prez and jamal adams
to go maybe make a blockbuster deal for
deshaun watson
or even russ what do you think the is
going on in joe douglas's mind right now
yeah my guess is knowing joe and knowing
kind of how he was raised in the
business with ozzie newsome and
and just piling pics and and building an
organization
from from the draft that that's the
route he's going to go
now he and everyone else who's you know
quarterback needy carolina atlanta etc
they're kind of waiting to see where
some of these quarterbacks go in terms
of the veterans and
we'll see what the free agency is as
some of the guys get sorted out
in the trades but ultimately
if you think zack wilson is is going to
be
anywhere close to as good as sam darnold
and i i think
the move is to try to move sam darnold
and and get some more
draft capital for him and build the
whole organization in a two-year span
i mean the jets have two first-rounders
this year two first-rounders next year
i want to say eight picks in the in the
first three rounds combined
so they've got a lot to work with and
then if you are able to move sam for
whatever the compensation is let's say
it's a pair of twos
or a one and a four or whatever it is
then then you have that in addition to
what you already have so you bring in
zach
from byu and and you yeah you're gonna
struggle for a year or two
but then you have the organization that
you're looking to build
two years down the road what's your
evaluation of zack wilson compared to
sam darnold when he was coming out of
usc because we talked to
uh we we talked to coach setani of byu
and the way he talked about zach wilson
being a gamer
being all about ball he doesn't play
video games he watches film of the nfl
it sounded exactly like what i heard
about darnold coming out of usc
quite frankly they're actually really
similar and i get asked this question a
lot
obviously because the decision that that
the jets are going to have to make
and the similarities are yes the
maturity
and loving ball but i also think kind of
the magic inside the pocket the ability
to extend plays
change arm angles and and sense where
the rushers are coming from now
you look at sam in the nfl and you say
well your evaluation was off
but you also have to look at the
supporting cast i mean
he's never had a good offensive line
he's at at best he's had an
average offensive line he's never had i
mean who's his best
wide receiver that he's had during his
career
who's the best running back that he's
had and and there's been no sustaining
of those players that have come in and
out so
i i still think sam darnold can be a
really
really high-end starter in the league
but it might
be time for a scene change if you will
to go to somewhere else
and and to kind of start over and if not
then then
the jets have to sit there at number two
and probably trade back
for a team that's trying to move up like
a carolina
as i mentioned from eight to two or
atlanta from four to two
to go get zach wilson and take advantage
of that as well so
they have options but i mean make no
mistake joe douglas
this year and next year in the draft
will define
kind of his legacy and what the jets
organization will be for the next 10
years todd mcshea here on the rich eisen
show look todd i mean
uh i i everyone knows i'm a jet fan you
know um
but but i am talking about it
significantly because they are
the the major domino uh of the draft
and and potentially free agency with
some of their decision making and
so uh let's wave a wand um
and say that the best spot for sam
darnold would be
what and uh let's include the fact that
mike lafleur
is bringing in the shanahan system or is
it best for him to go to the actual
shanahan system
wave a one and say the best spot for sam
darnold would be
this place because he deserves to have
this happen for him after everything
that you just
chronicled go forward i think i think
carolina would be really interesting
and i you know i just looked at them
last year and they're a better team
than than people think they had eight
games that they lost by one score
and they just they need a dude at that
position a guy who can
who can finish off drives in the fourth
quarter so i to me
you know they're sitting there sitting
back at number eight in the draft
this year and they can't control what
they you know what they can do
necessarily because
we could see trevor lawrence go one zack
wilson go to
um you know justin fields trey lance all
go in the top four picks
and and who knows what's gonna happen
with mac jones and i know they like mac
jones a whole lot
from the senior bowl but i would rather
have sam darnold even though i'm gonna
have to pay him a lot more moving
forward
than mac jones but uh but darnold to me
just would add that value and and may
take them from a team that's picking
eight overall to
a team that's making a run in the
playoffs now normally todd mcshay we'd
be
we'd be coming back from the combine
right about now know
after seeing a bunch of kids spin it and
then maybe a couple of kids not because
their agents said don't and i'd be
pissed because i'm sitting in the booth
trying to make some chicken salad out of
that moment but
um so uh evaluate these guys
right now obviously there's no combine
we've seen a pro day out of trevor
lawrence give me give me your
quarterback evaluations as we sit here
prior to the new league years starting
well trevor lawrence to me
is i have the highest grade on him that
i've had on a on a quarterback
since going back to 2012 with andrew
luck
we all know his ability um you know that
the only the only question i have
because i don't know is
how does he process information and all
sorts of those things and
and it's been tough for teams this year
without the one-on-one contact to
to really dive into all that but his
maturity
his leadership and and the way he his
demeanor on the sideline i've done
nine games live within the last three
years and just watching him after
you know incomplete passes that were
drops and interceptions and
touchdowns and all the other things he
just he never wavers
zach wilson is different and it's a
different evaluation because two years
ago he had a shoulder injury innate had
a hand injury
but this past year he comes out and
plays in in a
strange season against not great
competition but was exceptional
and showed a lot of patrick mahomes
deshawn watson
baker mayfield type kind of qualities in
terms of the ability to to extend plays
and just make plays and have
those instincts so i i think zach wilson
is clearly the number two quarterback in
this class and i'll be shocked if he's
not the number two pick
then after that it gets interesting
because justin fields from ohio state
is so physically gifted and he has good
football intelligence
but he played in a system where
everything was kind of tailored for him
is quarterback friendly
and he likes to see his receiver come
open and as you know in the league
you've got to be able to anticipate
throws
and kind of trust where your receivers
are going to be
and i that's that's one area that he has
to develop
and then trey lance had one game in the
strangest game i've ever seen in college
football
a showcase game against central arkansas
he has just 17 starts coming out of
north dakota state
and he played at the small school level
so you're talking about four
quarterbacks that
could all go in the top four but they're
very different prospects because of all
those reasons
and then matt jones bursts on the scene
this year after just four starts the
prior year went to a tonga by lower
got injured at alabama and got better
and better and better but he's not as
mobile as trevor
or zach or fields or lance so
he's gotta play great with his mind and
he's gotta be
extremely smart and understand what
defenses are doing it and he showed that
steve sarkeesian said he you know i i
gave him towards the end of the season
more install packages than i have ever
with any quarterback that i've worked
with at the college level
so they're five unique guys they're all
supremely talented but they're all very
different too and that's what makes the
evaluation
so unique because you talk to guys in
the league and and one team loves trevor
another team
says well jack might be the best
quarterback you know it just depends on
who you talk to
so then uh who are you talking to that
you can
that that that all right instead of that
hold on let me rephrase that
which teams do you think are in the
first round quarterback market
who who do you think is true like who
are you hearing uh
jacksonville jacksonville clearly
obviously yes i mean
outside of outside of you know jets
jacksonville
um carolina carolina is
is starving for a quarterback
and because of the reasons that i stated
earlier right
it won't shock me at all if they make a
move up if assuming they don't
they don't get a quarterback in free
agency or or uh
trade atlanta in atlanta is the most
interesting team because
matt ryan the cap hit that you're going
to take over the next couple of years
i think matt ryan still has a lot of
good football left in him
and it wouldn't shock me at all if matt
ryan was still atlanta starter in two
years i'm not talking just next year two
years
but do you want to bring in a
quarterback now and develop them
especially a guy like a trey lance from
a small school
with just 17 starts so that you're set
for your future
so those are the the four teams to me
that really jump out
and then you know you look at chicago
after that down the line
new england what's new england gonna do
with their quarterback situation so
there are several teams denver's another
one as well in san francisco i didn't
mention
who i had trading up in this recent mock
draft and number nine to go get mac
jones so
there are there are five quarterbacks
that should go in the first round and
there are about
seven teams right now that have
quarterback needs
now how that shifts with free agency and
trades is is what we're all kind of
waiting to see
yeah i i i want to dwell on the new
england for a second certainly because
if you say san francisco is going to be
going for mack jones that means jimmy g
might be
available and that might be a fit too
certainly because you know here are the
names of the quarterbacks that
that that um that bill belichick has
drafted
okay tom brady obviously rohan
davey cliff kingsbury matt castle kevin
o'connell
zach robinson ryan mallett jimmy g
jacoby brissette danny etling and jared
stidham
first-rounders none of them
first-rounders
so that's what i've been saying and i
told our graphics people to
build that exact graphic because i i
don't think and you know what every time
i think something about new england they
wind up doing the opposite so take it
for what it works
but um but i i just get the sense that
that bill will will wait and he'll try
to see what's going on with
the free agents and the movement and and
see what happens but i don't envision
him
giving away multiple draft picks to go
up into the top seven eight spots to go
get a quarterback especially
when and just to make this clear it's
trevor
and then there's a gap and then it's
jack wilson and then there's a gap
and then those other three quarterbacks
you can kind of debate in my opinion
and so i don't know that you you're
trying to move up
what does it cost to move up from 15 to
2 to go get one of the
two top quarterbacks and otherwise
is it worth giving up all those draft
picks in order to get one of the
you know the third fourth or fifth best
quarterback in this class
i don't personally think so and i i i
just don't envision bill belichick doing
that
last a couple minutes here with todd
mcshea nfl draft analyst college
football analyst right here on the rich
eisen show
um the concept of herbert's much better
than tua because of what we just saw
from their
rookie years how do you handle that
process of evaluation
i think you have to give to a time you
know obviously herbert outplayed them
um but but two have practiced well
enough
and showed enough to the coaching staff
to to get an opportunity to play
and we we all kind of such short-term
memory
this guy i was standing 10 yards from
him when he suffered that hip
injury and and he had to bounce back
from that we didn't
most people thought including myself
that he would just red shirt this past
year
take the year off and continue to to get
right physically so
he's come a long way from from what we
saw with that injury to
to where he was last year now he
obviously has to play better
and that you hear some things coming out
of miami i don't know you know what's
true and what's not true at this point
but i i certainly wouldn't give up
on a quarterback after the first year i
mean we've seen so many times with guys
that have had really brutal rookie
seasons that have gone on
to be hall of famers so i you got to
give these quarterbacks a little bit of
time and to your point
when we open the segment you know teams
are now
so much more willing to move
quarterbacks after two three years
and just move on from them but josh
rosen's a great example that worked out
really well so far for arizona but i i
still think
you got to develop these guys you got to
give them time and especially into a ton
of i alois situation
coming off that hip injury you got to
give them a minute
well i mean you know the the cardinals
moved on from rosen because they
they had the first overall selection and
kyla murray and could start the clock
again with somebody with a
a greater physical skill set you would
say than then obviously
um josh rosen and the jets if they move
on from darnold
they would move on for somebody that
they would start the clock with all over
again would you
move to it for desean watson if you're
miami because you know that desean would
probably
not mind going to miami south florida's
apparently on his
hit list and they do have the the
no number i mean miami for starters
could just flip
to a and also houston's first-round
draft pick
back would you do that if you're miami
would you do that yeah of course
okay no question well i mean obviously
it would be more it would
probably be a lot more expensive than
just it'll be the eighth pick with
miami's at 18 i think is the second pick
and probably you know at least another
first round or maybe two more first
round picks you do that but yeah i would
do it i would do it for the shop
i would and i and i i just told you all
the reasons i think you should be
patient with tour
but this desean has proven you know what
you're getting
he's still young he wants to go
somewhere
where the situation is better and
there's more consistency
and miami believe it or not and i know
they're picking at eight and i know
you know they've had they've had so many
problems for so many years but this is
the best
organization that miami's had in terms
of the coaching staff
and their front office in a long ways
since i've been doing this actually so
you know about 20 years so then last one
for you what if you're the bears
who would probably have to take out a
second and third mortgage on their
houses
plus khalil mack and roquan smith would
you do that
for deshawn would you do that
i would i would i i would love to just
give away draft picks and not
not give away those two standouts on the
defensive side but
yeah you're gonna have to give up a lot
especially picking it at 22. i mean
and and everyone knows that they that
their quarterback hungry
and that they want to get up in the top
10 if they can't get a veteran
quarterback so
you you have them right where you want
them so you're probably going to get a
better deal out of chicago in terms of
the long term
um if that's how it all works out but
yeah i would in either situation i would
if i was miami or chicago
if i had a chance to get to sean and it
wasn't completely
unreasonable um it's going to be
unreasonable but
as long as it's not beyond that i i
would make the move
todd appreciate the time thank you let's
do this again soon
always enjoy our chats at mcshay13 on
twitter at t
mcshay on instagram follow todd mache
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here